[Musik]
ich heiße kiste komme aus hessen
brustschwimmen wir seit elf jahren
deutschland hat ja der druck jetzt die
müssen gewinnen und wir wissen alle wie
deutschland spielen können und ich denke
wir werden die nächsten schritte
diese schritte verbessern spieltag
samstag also was schwede hat man
eigentlich nicht zu verlieren gegen
deutschland deshalb kann ich das nur als
zurücklegen und das genießen weil das
ist ärgerlich aber wie im übrigen ist es
nicht aber ich denke dass deutsche hast
du mir druck als schwere wenn man
spieler von daher sehe ich hoffe dass
ich das mit ein deutscher freund oder
bekannter sehen können und sind glück
auch wenn wir da gewinnen könnte wenn er
immer schön das leben zu stärken
ich denke das spiel ist sehr ähnlich wie
italien schweden in die playoffs wo
schweden als kollektiv sehr gut dahinter
gestanden haben und versucht haben
vielleicht anderen zwei konter zu
kriegen und vielleicht einen rein
kriegen aber es wird das spiel auf die
schweizer seite zu werden werden denke
ich sehr tief stehen müssen weil die
individuell halt nicht so stark sind die
deutschen ein volk ein gutes spiel hat
gegen deutschland damit jetzt extrem
schwierig für schweden überhaupt was zu
kreieren
ich denke es wäre ein bisschen glück
haben das gehört auch immer dazu
und der vielleicht kriegen die herren
ein tor rechtzeitig vor ende der herbst
erste halbzeit wo das maintaler
psychologische vorteil kommt in halbzeit
zu gehen mit 1 0 im rücken vielleicht
reicht das dann um diese vielleicht 10
zu gewinnen oder damit 11 vielleicht
sowieso trinken aber es wird schwierig